we have one last head-to-toe makeover
today we get to honor maria mccary an
incredible mom of three from minneola
new york let's meet her
hi i'm maria mccary i'm 61 years old i
live in minneola i have three amazing
beautiful children everybody depends on
me to take over and do things around the
house the chores the gardening the food
shopping and then i also take care of my
mother who's 101. i barely look in the
mirror because sometimes i look and i
see a woman who is aging who looks a
little stressed but i'm very happy
within
i want my inner self to shine but i also
want my outer self to shine along with
it i really have put myself aside and
that desperately needs to be fixed
i would like to change my hairstyle put
on makeup i would like to have really
nice clothes that make me feel fantastic
i need new look i would love drew to do
my makeover because she is going to make
me beautiful and shine
please say hello to maria's family james
caitlin and theresa my god hi guys
i would love to know from you guys what
is one thing
about your mom and wife that we should
know today
she uh she
doesn't go out of the
her way to take uh care of herself and
to go uh to beauty parlors and get uh
facials and and and manicures and things
like that i'm glad that she's gonna be
the star for for even for a day it's
it's uh it's wonderful that she's got
this opportunity
but we're excited to honor her today yes
i love a big reveal okay drew it's
amazing and maria and i are discussing
what the best tip for foundation
for a more mature skin is you don't want
to wear foundation because you have
beautiful skin but sometimes it helps
just to even out the base and for that
you need something that's not just a
face with heavy pigments in it you want
something that has a serum in it so it's
got hydrating properties actually more
skin care properties than it is makeup
we've got the perfect one for you and
i'm going to teach you how to apply it
because it's all about the buff you want
to buff buff buff buff until you're
bored because then it doesn't rest in
any fine lines
also a great tip use a wet sponge to
apply it wet damp sponge to apply it and
pop it in because then again it doesn't
sit and it really gives you that
beautiful even complexion
[Applause]
welcome back
thank you santa i cannot wait to see
maria's head to toe makeover if there's
any better hand she can be in i don't
know them other than my dear sister in
beauty zanna let's take a look at drew
crew members enter roberts rossi who is
backstage right now transforming our
guest maria there's just no better hands
to be in than someone authentic like
zanna so i can't wait to see maria's
final look and we hope that she is happy
beauty week is wrapping up and i
couldn't think of a more perfect way
than to end it with my sister in beauty
and makeup expert and fashionista
correspondent extraordinaire santa
roberts rousey
and uh she's been helping me backstage
um you know kind of work a new look and
maria's husband james and her two
daughters kaitlyn and theresa are here
in the audience are you guys ready oh
yes i think you're going to be blown
away all right we're gonna take a look
at a beautiful picture of maria before
and let's see how zana worked her magic
and see what mariah
[Applause]
oh my gosh i can't believe oh oh my god
i'm really crazy i'm shaking
i feel beautiful
jim
home run
if i wasn't on the stage right now i'd
run down there and hug them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
would you like to give us some tips and
tricks um some things that you did you
could take us through so first up hair
there was a good 15 inches taken off
here then it's loaded with these caramel
highlights which really are warm and
they bring out the warmth in the face
then when it comes to the dress
so the idea here there's so many figure
flattering moments in this one simple
dress the v-neck draws the eye down
decolletage hot area to show off hot and
then you've got these vertical stripes
in the rib so it's a ribbed vertical
stripe which again elongates draws the
eye down and then we have makeup so when
it came to the eyes we just
blended the eyeshadow when it comes to
eyeshadow the best rule blend until you
are bored the more you blend the more
natural it's going to look
and then when it comes to mascara we add
on maybe two layers but once you've had
one layer
wait like 30 seconds before you add the
second layer it'll dry down a little dry
down though not full dry down because
then when you add the second layer
you're going to end up with the clamp b
crispy clumpy lashes
well what i love about your look also is
that it is very natural
like this is you this is all yeah oh
thank you so much i can't believe i'm
here this is crazy but it's the happiest
day
um thank you guys so much all right
everybody
oh gosh i'm being told that we are only
95 beauty tips we have five more to get
to santa help
okay
help i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead tip
bring us to 100
hair tip do not dry your hair from when
it's sopping wet make sure it's 30 to 40
percent dry before you start doing it
otherwise it's gonna fry your hair you
do not want to put excess heat ever hot
tip
i tip
the easiest thing to do in the morning
ice under your eyes
diy cryotherapy de-puffs instantly and
when it comes to skincare don't apply
any of your skincare your serum your
oils your moisturizers
until you've come out of the shower your
paws are at their most receptive because
they're open and they will just seep in
all the goodness that you're putting on
my best fashion tip do not just go for
trends
they don't work for everyone just do
what suits your body type and your vibe
we are almost there what is the 100th
tip xana
just do what makes you feel good in your
own skin because being happy on the
inside will just light you up on the
outside i agree it's different for
everyone
there's not a blanket rule
what works for one person may not work
for another
make it work for you and be you there's
only one of you how beautiful is that
all right santa roberts rossi you are my
sister in beauty and best partner in
crime maria mccary thank you to you and
your beautiful family thank you
everybody for choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so take it with you
[Music]